[Musique]
une expérience incroyable et c'était
vraiment quelque chose d'exceptionnel
vous entendez l'ambiance vous entendez
des gens derrière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je viens de nice j'ai pris la route
ce midi pour accompagner un militant
texte et marseille et de tous les
bouches-du-rhône et soutenir les comités
locaux qui sont son terrain bonjour
madame pour emmanuel macron merci à vous
pour donner un ordre d'idée c'est un
marathon on a quand même présidentielle
et là nous sommes dans ce sprint final
donc il faut se mobiliser tous les jours
partout dans la région
[Musique]
ça fait cinq ans enfin plus de 50 je
suis engagé et le déclic ça a été manuel
macro c'était sa manière de parler sa
manière de faire la politique qu'on
n'avait jamais vu ça auparavant
certaines personnes sont comptes c'est
normal d'autres souhaitent discuter
d'autres vous sentez vous pouvez les
convaincre donc on va discuter avec lui
on va échanger avec lui sur les ponts ou
peut-être nous sommes pas en accord mais
le plus souvent ça se passe très bien
bonjour monsieur pour l'élection
présidentielle
moi je me situe plutôt vers la gauche et
je porte aujourd'hui ses idées au sein
d'une partie
[Musique]
à la maison on avait l'habitude de
parler politique on avait l'habitude de
débattre devant des informations non non
c'est pas quelque chose qui est apparue
ça s'est amplifié et c'est peut-être
pour ça que mon engagement s'est
concrétisée finalement ce matin on fait
une action de terrain pour finir
d'inviter les gens au meeting d'après
midi le nom prénom et adresse mail et
pour leur présenter le programme et
après on se retrouve au pharo nous un
peu plus tôt que les autres parce qu'on
doit préparer l'ambiance donc tout
organisé
[Musique]
sa première bracelet tout le monde a un
bracelet tout le monde a un bracelet
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on va faire ça dépend un
peu des gens certains comme moi j'ai la
chance de faire partie de la bulle
présidentielle qui va accompagner le
candidat jusqu'à la plateforme
[Musique]
après il ya là certains un nombre de
militants engagés depuis longtemps
méritants qui vont monter sur scène avec
le candidat qui vont chanter voilà à
l'avancé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne cédez pas à la peur aux à quoi bon
ne cédez pas aux au grand relativisme
qui consisterait à dire tout se vaut
celui qu'on aime pas forcément mais qui
est encore en marche et l'extrême droite
parce qu'on vous a forci la tête que
c'était la même chose non ce n'est pas
la même chose et qu'on puisse dire que
emmanuel macron et marine le pen c'est
bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet ca c je
trouve ça honteux et c'est un peu on l'a
un peu trop entendue dans le paysage
politique ma emmanuel macron sur la
droite extrême alors finalement mais
c'est faux c'est archi faux et sur le
bilan si on peut en dire de truites
c'est pour les jeunes le pass culture à
300 euros pour les jeunes étudiants la
plateforme parcours sup avant c'était du
tirage au sort les repas crous à 1 euro
pendant la crise qu'ovide aulas s'en
sont peut être très fier du programme
emmanuel macron là c'est la fête
[Musique]
moi je suis confiante je pense qu'il va
remporter l'élection mais il faut garder
en tête que rien n'est joué avant le 24
au soir il reste un second tour il
falloir mobiliser les gens
[Musique]